each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
I'm systems that you make
okay okay and so I'm going to talk today
about a facility at University of Texas
in the geology department that has a
high-resolution x-ray scanner capable of
scanning both small and medium and
somewhat larger sized objects at very
high resolution with lots of x-rays and
photons that result from those x-rays
but my interest are in the area of
morphology and what we can what the how
morphology helps us explain and
understand what happens in the in the
world around us historically the field
of morphology and anatomy was one that
was associated with with illustration
and the great anatomist of previous
centuries were always illustrators but
today we have the advantage of being
able to capture morphological
information digitally and that digital
revolution has had an enormous impact on
morphology and anatomy and specifically
although 2d scanners and cameras collect
digital information about morphology you
can take a picture of a specimen or an
animal or plant what has really made a
difference is they built you to capture
these same organisms these same features
in three dimensions the scanner that we
have is a is comparable to a medical
scanner except that rather than the
scanner moving around you as you are
inside a scary dark to the organism or
the specimen itself rotates this is a
obviously works only on things that are
already dead and on a wide variety of
objects with varying degrees of density
we have very high resolution systems
capable of resolutions down to a few
microns the workflow here the data flow
here is that the actual
scan produces something called sonogram
which is a the actual image shot from
the detectors as the specimen rotates
around frequently 1200 1600 or 2000
shots as he as the specimen rotates
those are reconstructed using a back
projection algorithm into actual slices
typical data set for us is anywhere from
500 to 2000 1000 by a thousand pixel
slices 16-bit def color depth and so we
get data sets anywhere from one to four
gigabytes in size our protector
capabilities are probably going to be
doubling in the near future so we'll get
2k by 2k resolution now we're starting
to get quite sizable data sets that are
hard to actually manage for normal
applications what we do with those data
are various primarily for most of the
applications that we're doing and we
started as a digital library project
funded by the National Science
Foundation my project yet i'll explain
more about some of the other
applications and which our goal was to
scan and disseminate information about
some of the rarest and most important
Natural History specimens on earth and
so our immediate goal was to scan those
specimens and use visualization software
on those to produce imagery and
animations that let people actually see
those objects in three dimensions those
products are also part of our workflow
we produce animation frames and movies
that result from those using a variety
of proprietary applications and so I'm
going to show you a little bit about I'm
going to go over to a browser and show
you the facility itself the digital
library that has been the mainstay of
our dissemination output for the past
six years a little bit about UT CT which
is our recent digital archive for
disseminating the raw data and I'll
briefly mention a some possibilities
where we might be going next year
so let's go over here and go to a
browser the facility itself is that it
also in SF supported multi-user facility
that that is located in the geology
department it is tirely a soft money
operation operates on a combination of
NSF funds and user fees we're probably
the most successful least NSF keeps
telling us multi-user facility that they
support in part because we have so many
outside collaborators we end up with 50
to 150 outside collaborations or clients
a year who bring things into scan and
the types of things that they bring in
to scan are just you know almost
anything that you can imagine it might
have something on the inside of it and
so so many of these are geological
samples that I don't really know a lot
about the these are meteorites for
example here in which the important
thing with the the vesicles that are
located inside of them we have these are
this is an oil I mean a drill core in
the bottom of a open pit gold mine in
Colorado that they were not sure whether
there were further gold samples there
that it took a core in this case you're
seeing a a plane inside of the the
inside of this core that in actually
those little red flecks are actually
gold and so that's a that's one of the
kinds of geological samples that we do
we also do a variety of engineering
samples these are asphalt cores asphalt
is a big business animar kabli big
business everybody wants smart asphalt
that last and has the right about a
permeability and does all these things
that make our roads better and it turns
out that's big science and so so when
they build an out make an asphalt core
once they've done that they have no idea
what's on the inside how they ever fit
together and so forth and so they bring
this to us and we scan a lot of asphalt
course this is a interesting book that
was a we scanned as just a demonstration
raishin of showing that you can in fact
look inside of these folks probably
going to take too long just low I won't
do that but you can actually read the
book as you scan through it and so any
rate so that's the facility itself the
digital library that I'm associated with
is the digital more project we have
approximately 500 biological objects
that we have scanned everything from
flowers to fossils dinosaurs fish birds
our most recent scan thing here is a
baby and an adult skull of a emperor
penguin the one from the most recent
movie so these are specimens that for
which we have made animations at one
loaded hear that so this is a 3d
rendering volume rendering using
proprietary visualization software for
which we have over the course of
probably three or four hours shot at 90
frame animation save that out as
quicktime movie we actually only provide
on the site these web sized versions of
these movies we make these in much
larger richer formats but the
distribution distribution of those is
more difficult because of their size so
typical movies for us that full-size
range from anywhere from 10 to 50
megabytes the amount of detail in these
this is reduced this is actually about
half twice again as big as my screen is
is significant and and these are the
rendered views of the data we also offer
the capability of looking at the raw
sliced data itself this is the skull of
the specimen the adult specimen of the
emperor penguin now one of the things
that's a little hard to get your your
mind around with these data that differs
from what you do when you snap a picture
is that these are true geometrically
correct data so we have this skull now
rendered as a movie but we also have
those data correctly proportioned in 3d
space and so this slice viewer that you
see here which is a fairly low
technology java applet okay does in fact
retain at all times the Korea create
correct geometry of the specimen so i
can ask a simple question like you know
how long is the skull see it 187 point
to two millimeters and that's a correct
number and so so part of our workflow
issues that we have this metadata
associated with the voxels the voxels
have a geometry and whenever we carry
those into the next step is important
for us to manage that particular aspect
of the information and so so this has
been our primary output format for the
last six years it's great it's very
popular it's one you know Scientific
American Awards it was one of Yahoo's
top 25 science sites a couple years ago
we get a lot of interests of educational
audiences a lot of outreach types of
purposes but it's a little bit maybe a
lot low on resolution for scientific
applications the the full resolution
data sets the full size animations when
scientists are looking at individual
features that they're interested in and
I have a movie here which has been
segmented so we have now got somebody's
actually gone into the individual the
box Wilson notated annotated them as to
what parts they were this is a larger
set of those there's actually a subset
of these of hierarchically organized and
so each one of those given a different
transfer function and the resulting
voxels are colored in an animation this
type of data and even at higher
resolutions of what the scientific
community requires and so we have a year
so ago started a project to disseminate
these information and provide tools for
examining the full-size datasets and
that is something we call you TCT we
have only a small number
of datasets on hand i'm going to after
i'm going to show you some
demonstrations this i'll talk a little
bit more about it when i move back to
powerpoint the the architecture of this
is that we are storing the information
in sequel server the individual images
outside of that was a challenge the
processes of loading those data and
managing them has proved to be something
that took us a while to get worked out
and we're still not yet having that we
still as of this point still don't have
a completely smooth workflow process for
moving the data from our lab in to this
system but we've got many of the pieces
in place and and much of the
functionality is it's starting to get
there what we offer right now or a
couple different reasonably
straightforward visualization system
tools we have a light table viewer that
let's let's let you look at the data in
a analyte table view needless to say you
can pop on individual frames and look at
those this is really good for sort of
getting a feeling for the data what's
involved in that if that wasn't a big
enough picture you can change the scale
on these things and look at it slightly
larger versions to see see what it is
that's present in the data it's a very
quick way to go through the data we also
have another applet on this at this site
that in fact needs to have a fair amount
will work done to it and and this in
case um we're looking it up and a mouse
and so put in a place where there is
something there and again offering views
through three primary cardinal
orientations okay so let me talk now go
back to a slightly better description of
the site and what's happening okay so in
theory what we'd be moving into this is
is is 10 to 15 datasets a week if we
actually moved all of our data flow out
of the lab into the system and that
would be a lot of work on our current
system in which involves
ftp and stuff and piping stuff into
scripts and so forth and so we are very
definitely interested in improving that
process we collect as part of it collect
the metadata that keeps track of the
geometry the information about the the
imagery about the data set ancillary
imagery the data are maintained in SQL
server the server itself that you just
saw is Apache PHP script one of the
important steps in this is that we do
the data set comes out is tiff slices
through the data as it was scanned but I
showed you in each of these cases views
through the data in other the other
Cardinal orientations horizontally and
sadly and those images have to be
produced ahead of time producing them on
the fly would be too slow so we do those
in a script using an IDL and we load the
data with Java and a set of stored
procedures that ultimately call text
copy exe de individually load each image
one at a time and so we have a
architecture and so that workflow as it
stands now is we have to pee these
things over we do an interface thing we
start the java application that loads
the data it converts the data from
16-bit 8-bit we maintained of 8 and
16-bit versions the data we can make a
jpeg version of the data all the slices
get loaded in the database and sort of
magically appear on the website and so
so that's our current where we are okay
but I want to also spend some time
talking about the the process that gives
rise to this being an important aspect
of a larger enterprise and that is the
scientific enterprise associated with
the tree of life the history of life on
Earth and current efforts to understand
the history of life and to talk about
the processes that are involved in that
and to look at the features on organisms
that are manifested by our understanding
of that tree of life and so I'm going to
go briefly through trying to keep going
fast here the general enterprise
of assembling the tree of life one that
starts with biological specimens and
museums and herb areum's the collection
of data the collection specimens and
data associated with them the creation
of taxonomy that keep track of the names
associated with these organisms these
are all done by systemic asst all of
those first steps are done by system it
is to work in museums who work on groups
of organisms the process of creating an
uncreated trees are recreating the
history of life is one in which we look
for characters that tell us information
about organisms and the features they
possess do that two ways we do it with
sequence data lots of people are doing
it with secrets later we can do it for
morphological data even when we do it
with sequence data we're interested in
the changes that happened on organisms
the morphological changes that happen
organisms that we can see with our eyes
and so the process of mapping morphology
on the trees or creating trees biologic
phylogenetic trees with morphology are
much the same in terms of the
informatics infrastructure so briefly
I've outlined here a diagram that
provides some of the steps that and I'm
going to tell you where the steps that
we're involved in after I go through
this and so natural history museums
collect specimens in the case of
morphology cameras and scanners collect
information about collect documentation
about features and they may be snapshots
they may be hand illustrations or
whatever they are they're all have to be
managed in the standard way if it's
digital cameras and 2d images they can
go right to your desktop for
observational purposes if they are 3d
data scanners they would have to be
visualized in the fashion that I just
talked about the scientists desktop and
what happens there I'm going to come
back to that in just a minute but the
process that most scientists undergo is
that they'll sit there and they'll take
a collection of organisms
some flowers okay and there may be 400
species of sunflowers in the world I
don't actually know that I'm not a
botanist I don't know why I picked it by
a botanical example but they will go to
museums they will look at images of some
flowers they will hold them in their
hands they will snap pictures they were
make drawings they 3d object that scan
them scan a seed and look on the inside
of it and they will take those 400 for
each of those 400 tax them they will
collect characters morphological
features this is something that has
happened forever okay Darwin noted
features of organisms and how they vary
between taxa so he recorded characters
and he recorded states of those
characters for individual taxa now that
process has happened time and again the
same organism for many times and one of
the sort of weaknesses of the entire
enterprise is that those the concept of
characters that are collected on on
organisms is one that has been
historically done time and again with
scientists individually coming up with
those characters and the names for those
characters we have pretty good concepts
for the basic structural elements of the
features of a few organisms the mouse
the human not much beyond that actually
most organisms on Earth have unspecified
vocabularies for the features that
characterize their morphology so the
skeletal elements of a goldfish or ones
that for which there are published
papers but there are no standards for
what each of those elements is called
humans have obviously had a lot of work
done on them night mice have had a lot
of work done on them but even the mouse
ontology for structural features is
incomplete and so so the process of on
what's happening on the scientific on
the scientists desktop is that he's
looking at these features he's looking
at the features of the sunflower he's
looking at the features of a mouse or
goldfish and looking for variation
amongst the tax in hand and when he does
that he were he or she records those in
a
matrix and that matrix will have
ultimately a code a 0 or 1 the
corresponds to some state of some
feature okay and so in this particular
case we're looking at some small critter
that i'm not sure what it is and so I
still don't know what it is and and has
decided that there are two states of
that okay and in this particular case is
documented them this is a desktop
application known as mesquite in which
it does have the capability of storing
this trait that has been it
characterizes the individual states for
this particular character the base of
the cloth tuft okay in tax on coke
Elodie's and variety of other tax on
here also have been either recorded or
not now the future that I want to talk
about here is that this is done
effectively in isolation okay this is a
great application its tort takes these
images and store something sticks on
your desktop and that's the end of it
okay this person is going to collect all
of these and the next time they look at
it it'll still be there but there's
nothing in our enterprise whatsoever for
the maintenance of this information the
reduced set matrix the ones and zeros
with the names of the columns and rows
is stored it's publishing a paper
publication it there's at least
opportunities to put it in public
depositories repositories but the
information about what constituted the
zeros and ones is gone forever except as
it occurs in a paper publication so dan
moran car and i are and gauged in a
recently funded project from the
National Science Foundation to try to
improve the infrastructure associated
with this process so this is a process
that starts with the collection of
morphological information be it from a
scanner or digital camera or hand
illustration or photocopy out of a bug
and takes that looks at it besides how
to break up that information into
characters and character stay
documents those in a desktop application
and now we're going to move to a
community infrastructure in which we are
have individual desktop clients much
like what we just saw but connected into
collaborative projects where individual
researchers are able to share those
results real time with their
collaborators checking in and out rows
columns and cells of those particular
matrices and that the words that are
correspond to this characters and
character states are ones that are
stored and community ontology that are
resolved through LS IDs and so that
enterprises one that we are at the
absolute infancy of in fact we're at the
emphasis so much that this is about all
that exists for it right now as a
diagram that is a conceptual view of how
our community might interact in a
fashion that corresponds to what a lot
of other communities are already engaged
in and so we we envision this as being
one in which we we prevent an awful lot
of redundancy that we improve the
accuracy of work that's done because the
same when we use a word we can see what
it means by looking it up in an ontology
the ontology zeeeee will have associated
with them documentation in the form of
digital imagery and words and
annotations and the communities that
come after us will have the benefit of
being able to connect the results of our
scientific research in terms of trees
and transformation for characters on
this trees with the underlying data that
gave rise to them and so I will stop
with that
questions here yes
absolutely right okay so so so we have
there's two pieces of information here
one are the characters that are
associated with the observations that
the systema dismay the other ones their
results their results or trees and the
mapping of characters on those trees
part of this larger infrastructure that
said its emphasis the ability to store
those trees community databases again up
until literally today those trees are
stored simply in journal paper journals
and if you want to look at them you've
literally hold them up and make a Xerox
of them and put it on your screen and
send it to somebody else to talk about I
mean really really no ability to talk
about these electronically so what we
what we envision is is that there's no
no reason that we have to assume a
particular classification particular
topology of trees to talk about the
characters okay okay yeah change things
out and so so for us that it that
disagreement about topologies is not
really the issue yes we fight about
those okay but the fact that matter is
is that the identification of individual
organisms were they what they fit how
they fit into the tree of life it's one
that's never going to be fully resolved
I mean it's nice to think that if we had
full full sequences on every organism on
earth would actually know what they what
the history of life was pathetic truth
is we would not still not know we know
we have complete sequences on chimps and
humans close on most of the other work
prom eights and we still aren't positive
those are things that are still we don't
have high degrees of certainty on things
that are the most studied on earth okay
so it's hard to imagine that we're ever
going to have the answer for the tree of
life so we're always going to have those
discussions but what we also have with
observations we make on this organisms
you know how many fingers they have how
many toes they have what color hair they
have and so so those are things that we
can talk about and talk about the impact
of those things given different
apologies of the Tree of Life this is
the basis of discussion it will be much
more educated discussion if those can be
mapped on there sometimes those mappings
are what actually helps us understand
whether or not one of those topologies
is more likely or not